hi this is John Backus from ortho
clinical Diagnostics I'm director of
scientific affairs at ortho and I'm
going to be talking today about Beatrice
microsuede technologies and assays is a
first step I wanted to inform everybody
that if you have any questions during
that presentation then please go ahead
and ask them within the chat and within
the Q&A area and they will be answered
after the talk itself
I'll also be holding a chat at I guess
it would be an hour from now
so noon Eastern Time 3 9 a.m. Pacific
time anyways with that I'd like to start
out by giving an overview of what I plan
on talking today about ok so what I'm
going to be focusing on today is vitro
some micro slide technology I'll be
talking about three general sections the
first one will be talking about color
metric slides for Beatrice but if part
of that I'm going to give a background
on the Beatrice microsflyn technology
I'll the focus of this section after the
background will be on talking about
Terra protein interference what it is
where it comes from what assays are
affected by it and how its minimized
using the Beatrice micro slide
technology the second section I'll be
talking about is the vitro step in
geometric slides for electrolytes and
focusing specifically on sodium and
lastly I'll be talking about the use of
the Beatrice BBC micro slide assay for
achieving accurate and neonatal
bilirubin results
so first here's kind of a general
overview of the microlight
technology this is developed in the late
70s at Kodak and it leveraged
photographic technology and so what you
see is that the micro slides themselves
have a variety of layers and each of
those layers has a functional has a
function that it performs within the
assay itself some of the benefits of
this technology in terms of general
benefits are that it's a very well
proven technology the technology has
been in use in clinical labs for about
30 years
it has the potential to significantly
reduce a variety of interference as some
of those I'll be talking about today and
another benefit is that it not only czar
no region prep but also there is no
water plumbing dry or drains which work
what means you don't require a clean
water source you don't require the
ability to plug in to a drain anything
along those lines and in terms of the
electrolyte assays another thing that
that it's the fact that there's no
electric electrodes to maintain and I'll
talk about that further so there's three
different formats that the microfibers
are in in terms of general formats
the first one is color metric and that
would be the person I'll talk about the
second is potential metric for
electrolytes and the third is immuno
rate and that third format I won't be
speaking about it all today so color
metric micro size
what this slide is showing is kind of a
general overview of a microsites o as I
mentioned there's a variety of layers on
a given a say will have the number of
layers that are required to do the the
various chemical reactions and other
activities that layers do with
slide in general slides has a number of
layers including the spreading layer the
sample is applied to the spreading layer
a reagent layer a registration layer and
a support layer I'll be speaking about
each of these in a little bit detail in
a loose a little bit of detail okay so
the spreading layer this allows very
small sample volumes on the order of a
few microliters to be spread evenly in a
lot of cases it minimizes interference
and I'll go into that in some detail by
capturing large molecules that can
interfere with chemistry reactions and
it also may contain a variety of
chemicals that are necessary in order to
break up interactions that the molecules
of interest have with other molecules so
in the reaction layer that that's
typically where the reagents are put
that the initially react with an analyte
to produce a product now this may not be
the actual detected product it may
actually be an intermediate the some of
the some of the chemistry reactions are
relatively complicated and there may or
may not be another layer between this
and the next layer below it that acts as
the semi permeable membrane in order to
only allow select molecules to move on
to the next stage again another means of
reducing interferences the next layer is
the registration indication layer this
is where the color itself is formed and
and the amount of color that is achieved
is is proportionate to the analyte
that's being measured and I'll be
speaking a little bit more about the
actual measurement of this color
the support layer provides a base for
the entire slide and at the same time
it's transparent allowing light to flow
through so that you can actually read
the color that's developed within this
slide so other layers that are sometimes
added include a scavenger layers on some
slides then there are scavenger layers
that actually consume potentially
interfering species within it within and
athing some examples of this include a
scavenger layer for ascorbic acid in the
uric acid slide and for divalent cations
and a triglyceride slide I another layer
that can sometimes be present as a
masking layer this is really only in the
Billy Rubin the BBC Billy Rubin slide
and it masks the color that is present
from hemolysis and the reason that that
needs to be done is because the Billy
Rubin itself is being measured in a
spectral region that overlaps with him
globin with the heme group of hemoglobin
okay so now that I'd be talking about
the actual detection methodology so if
you think about standards homogeneous
wet chemistry type assays then if you if
you're measuring light directly than I
be using transmission spectrophotometry
where you pass light through a liquid
and then any interferences that are in
the sample will actually also be giving
off light signal in the case of the
Micra side then you're actually
reflecting like sujin reflectance
spectrophotometry and because of the
presence of the spreading layer and the
ability to block signal that coming from
analyte so as an example itself then
there's much less interference
that is observed in this instance that
again the PVC Billy Ruben assays great
example of this where it's extremely
insensitive to large amounts of
hemoglobin contamination be if the
hemoglobin does not actually enter the
slide so here here's that just an
electron micrograph of the spreading
layer you can see it's a bunch of latex
particles and what this has the ability
to do is actually trap a variety of
interference and I'll be speaking about
one of those in particular so the the
interference I'll be talking about it
part is pair protein so first a little
bit of background because this is not
something that I know it's not something
that I knew a lot about going into
researching this area and I believe that
it's a relatively not well recognized
area out there so her progeny Mia is the
presence of excessive amounts of
monoclonal antibodies in the blood
those monoclonal in the globe you lines
are called pair proteins and the disease
itself is also called monoclonal
gammopathy it's caused by a quote
proliferation of b-cells as detected
typically in gel electrophoresis it is a
well-defined band in ejects by trees
actually so pair proteins are present in
a number of conditions I think that the
most well recognized one is multiple
myeloma there's a listing of several
here the most common is actually M Gus
or monoclonal gammopathy of undetermined
significance which is actually quite
common in older individuals the observed
prevalence based on the few published
studies that are out there
is somewhere in the 3 to 4 percent range
3 to 4 percent of all
over the age of 50 and six to eight
percent of adults over the age of 80 so
the individuals that you would be most
worrying would be more likely to worry
about I think in general in terms of
chemistry assay results because there's
a higher probability of them being
incorrect those individuals are also the
most likely to have this type of
interference so there's a variety of
ways in which pair proteins can
interfere with chemistry reactions I
think really the the simplest answer is
is that the majority of the interference
caused is caused by the presence of
acidic reagents in a chemistry
methodology when the acidic reagent
contacts the sample the pair of proteins
precipitate this can lead to false
readings and turbidity based or color
colorimetric assays and whether or not
you get a false positive or false
negative it's very dependent on how the
same how the signal is being read and
whether or not a baseline read is being
carried out there's been a lot of
literature out there that are looking at
para protein interference for a number
of key analytes and I think the most
well published analytes in terms of
interference are phosphate HDL total
bilirubin direct bilirubin calcium but
actually calcium is one where there's
been some obligation of it but not quite
as much as the others and and sodium
because if you have high levels of para
protein then you can actually get
incorrect results with indirect of
sodium methods which I'll be talking
about later in another section so one
one good question is how common is para
protein your experience there's really
been very little done in the way of
controlled studies to look at this there
have been a number of studies where you
know they would find it a number of
samples that gave odd results with one
platform and they would use reference
methods to compare against the what I'm
showing here is the study that actually
did a controlled study of a couple of
different platforms
they took 88 samples containing pair of
proteins from 52 patients and they
looked for interference on three
different assays on these two different
platforms two of these assays were also
assessed on the beach row slides because
the beatrice method has been repeatedly
shown to be insensitive to pair protein
interference for the assays that were
being measured so in terms of the
prevalence of interference in these pair
of protein containing samples actually
the majority 2/3 demonstrated
interference with at least one of the
six add visit was being assessed and 30
percent of specimens gave spurious
results in at least two the assays in in
the case of some of the assays than both
false positive and false negative
results were saying it is would be
expected none of the samples
demonstrated interference in either of
vitro flight assays that were tested so
that now that we've discussed the fact
that it's fairly common to have pair
protein you experience I guess another
question is can you predict whether or
not a sample that has pair of proteins
is going to demonstrate pair of protein
interference and given assay and the
answer is really there's no good way of
doing that here's just a quote out of
out of a CME publication on this topic
there's a poor correlation between the
type and level of proteins no likelihood
of artefactual abnormality
so this is actually a great article on
fictitious biochemical measurements
resulting from hematological conditions
it details a large number of published
incidences of false results in blood
assays and actually the majority of
these false results that they are listed
are due to pair protein interference and
I'm not sure how well people can
actually see the slide that I have here
but if you look at the bottom then then
it lists it actually this is only part
of a table it lists the conditions with
the causes list the assays that have
been shown to be affected and a list of
solutions have been published in the
literature and what I've highlighted is
is that for all of these assays shown
here that this one of the listed
solutions is to use the Beatrice Micro
slide technology for that given a say
either because of the fact that removes
protein or because well I actually in
the case of all of these is because the
pair of protein is actually removed
before the chemical reaction occurs so
here's a summary of this section on
parity interference ParaPro taneema is a
is a relatively common clinical
condition in individuals greater than 50
years old the main cause of it is
conditioned nerves and guts and the
prevalence of M Gus is very high in
older individuals ranging in the high
single digits in individuals over 80
years old pair progeny Mia can cause
interference in a wide variety of what
chemistry assay that believe that it's
on the order of 20 different assays
where this has been published the
interference is unpredictable and can
cause both false positive and false
negative results even within a man
even within a given manufacturer's assay
and probably the best way of reducing
this risk in terms of interference on an
automated platform is to use the
microwave technology because of the fact
that really I don't believe that there's
any published evidence that pair of
proteins directly interfere with the
Beatrice assays so I'm going to move on
to talk about potentiometric mic resides
so first in terms of what I'll be
referring to is indirect ISE or ion
selective electrode methods these
methods typically have a multi-use
electrode that needs to be rinsed
between samples there's issues related
to the need for frequent calibration
manual cleaning to prevent proteins
building up and interfering and the
really the big thing is is that beyond
those convenience issues there's also an
issue that there's a dilution of the
sample required and this can cause
falsely elevator falsely reduced values
which is particularly meaningful for
sodium and it can impact the
interpretation of sodium results in
particular so when the micro side
technology was being developed and the
feeling was that there could be a better
way of doing this and what was developed
were potentiometric mic resides the
there are potential metric assays for
sodium potassium and chloride i what
you're talking about is having a
disposable electrode one electrode for
tests there's no maintenance
there's no dilution of sample which is
important because of the fact that that
ensures accuracy of the measurement so
here's a general layout of how the
attention metric
respited is setup you've got a patient
sample and reference fluid and then
you've got a variety of layers including
anion selective membrane layer a
reference layer a silver chloride method
layer and a silver layer and then a
paper bridge at the top where the
samples are applied so the system itself
delivers equal amounts of reference
fluid and patient sample the ion
selective membrane allows only the ions
of interest to pass through the slide
you form two different half cells within
the slide and the silver and silver
chloride layer acts as an electrode you
measure the potential and determine the
difference between the electrolyte
reference fluid or ers and the sample so
now that I've talked about how the how
the beat rose micro slide method which
is a direct method works let's talk a
little bit about the indirect methods
and what I can see what I see is the
biggest issue with indirect methods and
that's what's called bime exclusion
effect or electrolyte exclusion effect
essentially what happens is is that all
indirect methods carry out a significant
dilution of the sample as part as part
of is part of the process of getting an
accurate result of what's actually in
the diluted sample however when doing
that then there needs to be assumption
about the amount of solids that are in a
sample and the displacement of liquid
that's carried out by those salads so by
fallas I mean protein and lipids
the assumption is made is that all
samples contain seven percent solids if
the give a given sample contains more
than seven percent solids then after you
do a dilution you're going to end up
with an inaccurate Leeloo result because
the fact that you actually have more
displacement than you anticipate if if
the sample contains less than seven
percent solids then you'll have an
incorrectly high value now in the case
of a very high protein levels then they
can be you know twice three times the
the Assumption obviously you can't have
less than zero percent solids so there's
a limit to to how how much of an impact
you can have from a reduction in
proteins and lipids now the reason this
is really important for sodium in
particular is because of the reference
range for sodium is very very very
narrow on its plus or minus about three
and a half percent so it's 135 to 145 is
typically the values that are used so
really that means 140 plus or minus five
millimolar so here is just a listing of
the potential misclassifications that
can occur you can get pseudo normal in a
trade mia in this case then if you have
low protein you can get sued normal
nutria mia from from well super
normative trimming in a patient who
truly has - nutria Mia or low sodium in
the case of pseudo Norman - tree mia due
to high protein which is the bottom one
in the table then this is a case of a
patient who truly has elevated sodium or
hyper entry mia and their red is normal
because the
the indirect method actually reads low
in the case of Sudan or Mediterranea the
top one is definitely the most common
it's definite the biggest concern on
with indirect icy methods in my mind and
I'll explain why pseudo hypernatremia
can occur when you have low protein in a
patient who has normal sodium values
because of false elevation the one that
I think that people are most familiar is
with is pseudo hyponatremia and this is
where you've got a patient who's got
normal sodium levels or normal nutri mia
but they've got high protein or lipid
levels so if you have a patient with her
protein emia that patient may have very
high levels of protein and you can get
you know extraordinarily low sodium
values so the normal range is 135 or 145
you can get somebody who actually has
normal sodium levels and yet what's
being measured is on the order of 120
milli molar so that would be considered
severe severe hyper I'm a hyponatremia
now there are well actually I'm going to
move on because I'm going to probably
discuss each of these in a little bit
more details so I've already kind of
gone through this this example where you
have a a true sodium level of right in
the center of the normal range with a
direct ioc method you're going to get
that same result and with an indirect is
a method in this sample that contains
20% solids again something like multiple
myeloma then the indirect method would
be giving a sodium level of 120 milli
molar which would be severe hyponatremia
this is if you have proper properly
implemented on laboratory algorithms you
can look at things like ion gaps and and
this can be caught so this is a severe
in a severely inaccurate result but the
it's only a serious issue if it's not
identified and I think that in most
cases this is well enough recognized but
it is identified now the other side of
the coin sort of Norman's train eeeh
this can occur in patients as I
mentioned one of the ways this can occur
is when you have abnormally low protein
and lipid levels in an individual that
has hyponatremia now a key point to make
here is is that
that there's a population that's a
fairly common population where there is
a high prevalence of both low protein
lipid levels and hyponatremia and that's
the ICU critical care population these
individuals will off I would say I
believe it's in that 80 to 90 percent of
individuals in the ICU will have below
normal levels of protein lipids and
these individuals also have a fairly
high prevalence of high hyponatremia
true hyponatremia so what you end up
with is you end up with a situation
where you have a significant number of
patients who may be being miscategorized
and there's no laboratory algorithm to
identify this error you know typically
what happens is that there are
algorithms to catch things that are out
of range when they shouldn't be there
it's less common to have algorithms that
actually identify when something falls
within a normal range but it shouldn't
have so the impact here is that patients
with hyponatremia may go untreated and
in a variety of these populations
whether or not at the ICU or heart
failure patients and there's a very
clear linkage between
between hyponatremia and poor outcomes
so you know obviously part of that could
be under diagnosis emerges ice could be
debated behind your die
so this is a really significant issue
from the perspective of patients not
being treated when they should be
treated so here's an example you've got
a sample that has three percent solids
versus a standard of seven percent and
so in a patient with a true sodium level
of 132 millimolar that would be
considered mild hyponatremia the direct
ISE method reads it is 132 and indirect
method reads it is 136 which falls into
the lower end of the normal range
another example that would be very
similar would be a patient who has
severe hyponatremia say 128 milli molar
would be read as 128 with the direct IC
method and with the indirect method then
they would be read as 132 now challenges
is that you know if you have somebody
with severe hyponatremia versus mild
hyponatremia then the way that you
actually balance their sodium level is
that or the aggressiveness with which
you take steps to balance their sodium
level is very different with somebody
with severe - hyponatremia then then you
need to go through a fairly defined
pathway - to minimize the risk of poor
outcomes due to the process of trying to
bring up their sodium level so in terms
of literature evidence for pseudo normal
new trainee a' there's three and three
independent studies third-party studies
that have independently concluded that
indirect ISE method generally
overestimate sodium values and critical
care patients the magnitude of the
overestimation and a couple these
publications they directly show that it
was that it was proportional to the
level of hypo protein emia or
hypoalbuminemia
one case over estimation by indirect
methods in these studies was shown to
miscategorized and when I say
miscategorized this is kind of in two
buckets of hyponatremic normal and
hypernatremia mek just using those three
buckets then twenty to thirty percent of
individuals in the ICU art can be
misclassified and this is really due to
a combination of two things one the
majority of them actually do have high
Pope wrote anemia and to a significant
proportion of them actually have true
hyponatremia so those that have true
hyponatremia a lot of those will be read
as normal and those that are normal a
significant proportion of them will be
read is hypernatremia all right so now
I'm going to move on to the third topic
of this session and this is talking
about using the beat Rose BBC slide for
measurement of bilirubin and neonates so
a little bit of background traditional
bilirubin methods you'll hear them
referred to as dial methods the dyes of
reaction was first applied to bilirubin
in 1916 by Vanderburgh and Neil and I
Muller on and the conjugated bilirubin
reacts rapidly and unconjugated
bilirubin reacts slowly unless you have
an accelerator such as caffeine or
something like that
to unfold and soluble eyes the molecule
and this is really the basis of the D
Billa so if you have a diva laughing you
don't have an accelerator if you have a
t-bill or total bilirubin assay then you
do have an accelerator so the the
Teva laughs a is typically called a a jg
method or a modified andressa Groth
method which is diet with caffeine is an
accelerator and the t-bill slide the
beat rose t-bill microsite is a database
t-bill method so in terms of D build
reactions then what's been done is an
effort to optimize conditions to
minimize the reactivity of the D bill a
say with unconjugated bilirubin however
even under optimal conditions depo a
they do give false reactivity in
neonatal samples containing only
unconjugated bilirubin and I'll give you
the easy proof of that here in a couple
of slides so the the vitro is BBC slide
for neonatal testing actually carries
out a direct measurement of conjugation
unconjugated bilirubin and it correlates
to HPLC in terms of the layout of the
slide itself then what you've got is
you've got a spreading layer to contain
caffeine so it releases effectively all
all of the bilirubin it's not tightly
bound to albumin and one difference
between this and TB laughs is the t-bill
assay the spreading layer on for
instance the t-bills slide contains a
chemical that actually releases all
bilirubin from health human in the case
of the BBC slide then bilirubin is
tightly bound to albumin which is
conjugated which is the subset of
conjugated bilirubin will not actually
enter the slide now for neat this is
something that needs to be accounted for
in adults but for neonates they really
have no albumin bound bilirubin so so
essentially adding up the unconjugated
and conjugated bilirubin that actually
enter into the slide does give you a
measurement
total bilirubin so after the sample has
gone through the spreading layer which
blocks on hemoglobin from entering the
slide as well through through a masking
layer that was through the combination
of it not entering the spring layer and
there being a masking layer below the
spreading layer then the sample of
contacts was called a mordant which
binds to the bilirubin both unconjugated
and conjugated and actually changes the
wavelength at which these these
molecules are red so if you look here
then this is kind of the principle of
the BBC slide what you'll see is that at
400 nanometers that both unconjugated
bilirubin or bu conjugated bilirubin DC
they give the same reflectance you'll
see that if you go up to higher
wavelengths then you see you see a
higher signal for unconjugated bilirubin
versus conjugated bilirubin so by
reading at a lower wavelength such as
400 and a higher wavelength in this case
460 then you can actually get a
measurement of total bilirubin and then
you have the information that's
necessary in order to deconvolve on the
spectra into what proportion of it is
due to unconjugated bilirubin versus
conjugated bilirubin so this is a
relatively complicated slide I'm going
to take a moment to go through it so if
you think about it from the perspective
of what's actually present in a sample
there's there's a couple of different
species that can be present in let's say
an adult sample you can have
unconjugated bilirubin you can have
conjugated bilirubin
the conjugated bilirubin can either be
singly conjugated or doubly conjugated a
subset of the conjugated bilirubin can
actually be tightly bound to albumin the
literature would say that that's a
covalent bond
I would say that the most recent we
would have would say that you know
there's certain questions that can be
raised in terms of whether or not it's a
covalent bond versus a very very tight
hydrophobic bond anyways
so those are the different methods I
mean they're different the different
species that can be seen for instance I
HPLC if you look at traditional daizo
based methods the tebow method will see
all of these the the direct bilirubin
method will see on the majority of the
conjugated bilirubin but it will also
see a small amount of the unconjugated
bilirubin in contrast the v-spec the
spectral Reem is done for the BBC slide
will separate out unconjugated from
conjugated with high specificity in an
adult sample then any of this Delta
bilirubin would actually be would
actually not enter into the BBC slide so
in order to get a measure of direct and
adults then you would actually need to
run both the t-bills slide which
measures all the total and a na BBC
slide and subtract out the unconjugated
the z unconjugated will all actually go
into the BBC slide now in the case of
neonates so if it's a similar of a
different story you know the simple
answer is there there is no Delta in
99.9999
percent of babies but they just they
just don't make it so what you have is
primarily unconjugated in some cases you
will have some conjugated although as
I'll mention later I think that people
may have a misperception in terms of how
frequent the presence of conjugated
bilirubin is in neonates there are
detectable levels of it so in the case
of the BBC slide then you know it's
quite simple you just have to you and BC
in the case of traditional methods as I
mentioned then you're going to get
totalled measuring total and a direct
measurement will give you primarily
measurement of conjugated but some
measurements of indirect is law and this
is this is just showing what I just said
that there's this uncertainty where you
don't you don't really measure all the
direct and you do measure a little bit
of the indirect to not believe for that
I'll move on to the next slide so
another point to make about bilirubin is
Billy room is very light-sensitive this
is really the basis of photo therapy but
it also effects samples that have been
collected in in collection tubes
particularly if they haven't been
collected and put into Amber bottles
immediately amber tubes immediately or
wrap foil what happens when when Billy
Rubin is exposed to light at least in a
patient sample visa it is very from the
testing we've done it does it's very
dependent on the matrix but in human
serum then when you expose that sample
polite then the bilirubin will create
both configurational and structural
isomers the configurational isomers
react with both
based chemistry and appear is is native
unconjugated bilirubin or bu on the BBC
slide it's so you know whether or not be
a wet chemistry method the vitro t-bills
slide or is a BBC slide all of those
methods will measure configurational
isomers essentially at a hundred percent
now the structural isomers that actually
impact all of the assays in this case
then you form an extra ring and that
molecule will not react with dyes a
reagent on the BBC slide what happens is
is you get a spectral shift when you
give this structural isomer so the the
damaged sample will be measured if if is
if it contains both bu and bc so this
can actually be used to a certain extent
as a quality check and the reason for
that is because the fact that the BBC
assay is extremely specific for for
separating out unconjugated bilirubin so
if you have a significant amount of
conjugated that's only going to happen
in reality out of very infrequent basis
and it's n when does that it's very
clinically meaningful but you you may
see instances where you get elevation of
the bc channel or the conjugated
bilirubin measurement on a BBC slide
simply due to the fact that samples are
being mishandled in terms of the overall
measurement if you think about it is
doing a t-bill the BBC slide is is much
less impacted by exposure to light
relative dyes of methods so if you get a
significant amount of light exposure you
make it say a 30 percent drop in a
standard t-bill assay whereas for the
BBC slide you would get a much smaller
drop but we you would see
in conjunction with that drop would be a
shifting of subbing the signal from the
EU channel to the BC channel so here's
here's kind of a summary of the Beatrice
BBC slide versus other methods
it measures unconjugated conjugated
bilirubin spectrophotometric Li whereas
other methods used as a base chemistry
either in the presence or the absence of
an accelerant yeah if if in the absence
of accelerant that would be a deep bill
assay and it's in the presence of an
accelerant you'd have a Tebow a setting
direct bilirubin is used as a surrogate
for conjugated bilirubin but it does so
with less-than-perfect specificity and
I'll be talking about that and again a
little bit further in a minute mote so a
point that I should emphasize and this
is something that is sometimes an issue
for clinicians to believe is the vast
majority of neonatal ceará don't have
detectable levels of conjugated
bilirubin so a bill in the you Nate
should be essentially zero most if not
any definitely the majority of the time
and and the challenge is that people are
used to seeing a value for a deep bill
so when they switch to a measurement
that's more specific then they they need
to be sometimes shown the evidence that
that method is more specific in that
really what they were getting was a
false result before so I've already
covered that what the second part the
first part of this comparative summary
with what I just said um you know and
and this is definitely in the literature
and out and I'll show it that next the
the BBC slide really gives
a zero resolved are essentially zero
result for conjugated bilirubin in the
vast majority of normal healthy
individuals including the units and
lastly in the summary then on bilirubin
is extremely light-sensitive the this
light sensitivity impact dyes old
methods quantitatively more so than the
BBC assay the BBC assay will have higher
signals in damp in light exposed samples
relative to dyes or methods both of them
will be less than the true measurement
but the BBC slide will also have kind of
to tell which is that you will have a DC
signal if you've had any significant
light exposure which is kind of a red
flag so when if you get a significantly
positive DC measurement in neonate who
has not undergone photo therapy then
that really strongly suggests that they
either either the sample has been
exposed to light or that they really do
have conjugated bilirubin which is
actually very clinically important now
so here's here's some data from a
publication from a group at Kaiser
including actually several thought
leaders in the Billy in the neonatal
bilirubin field on demonstrating the
beat rose BBC slide provides a more
specific measurement of conjugated
bilirubin relative to a standard D Bill
a say and if you just look at this table
below you see the results are pretty
striking that I if you compare the
measurement of a conjugated bilirubin on
the BBC slide to ad bill assay almost
none of the samples for D bill has has a
value of zero
where is for the conjugated bilirubin
measurement three-quarters of the
samples have a measurement of zero and
ninety-five percent of them
have a measurement of no greater than
0.3 in the case of the D bill assay
nearly half of them are both 0.3 and you
need to get up close to one before you
get to the point where 95% of them are
below that value now in the study what
they were really looking at with whether
or not the BBC assay because it provides
a more specific measurement actually is
more clinically predictive of issues on
biliary special liver issues so the 99th
percentile for the conjugated bilirubin
method was determined to be 0.5
milligrams per deciliter versus two
point one for the detail method and here
here's a quote from from the authors
false positive results are less likely
when using kind of a bilirubin than when
using direct bilirubin levels because
the conjugated bilirubin you measurement
is more specific only 0.3% of newborns
head elevated conjugated bilirubin above
of at least two but less than five and
thirty percent of these had disease
versus a dramatically lower proportion
for the D bill a say and and this this
presentation should be available for for
download and the reference is shown at
the bottom if you're interested in
finding out more I so what they
concluded was that using the features
BBC assay if you have a conjugated
bilirubin level of greater than 0.5 but
less than two milligrams per deciliter
in a newborn then you you need to rule
out infection because that's that a
common cause of that and and you should
observe the patient closely I in those
individuals that are greater than two
milligrams per deciliter then you really
have to look at the PATA biliary system
because a high proportion of the
neonates are actually going to well are
in the process of developing had a
biliary issues and with that I have
finished the the topics that I wanted to
cover I guess is a general summary the
the Beatrice micro slide technology is a
relatively well proven develop
technology it's been in the clinical
labs for 30 years however it still is
differentiated from all of their methods
in a variety of ways one of which is the
fact that it's really the the only
method that directly eliminates or
dramatically reduce as a as prize the
best I can say it's kind of one of those
three versus law things the the
occurrence of pair protein
interference in a variety of chemistry
assays I there's there's really no other
automated chemistry analyzer that is
capable of doing a direct electrolyte
measurement and the case of sodium then
that's really key for a fairly
significant population within the
hospital it's also important for I would
say geriatric patients and heart failure
patients is general populations even
outside the hospital I find by using an
indirect method do you increase the risk
of not catching patients who have true
hyponatremia in these settings or under
scoping the severity of the hyponatremia
in these settings and you also rent at
least a reasonable risk of calling
somebody hypernatremia who's normal so
the two sides of a coin area on one side
you would be under treating patients and
on the other side you'd be over treating
patients both of which are costly and as
has you know
potential consequences lastly the the
features method is the only automated
chemistry analyzer method that measures
on bilirubin spectrophotometric Li and
thus avoids the the issues of the bill
cross cross reactivity and I I'm not
sure if this was on one of the slides or
not but actually I didn't actually say
it the easy way to prove this to
yourself if you have any questions about
it would be to actually look at Katz's
survey data for samples for accuracy
samples particularly ones that have you
know say 10 or 15 milligrams per
deciliter Billy Ruby because these
samples the accuracy samples and anvil
survey are supposed that they're all
unconjugated bilirubin so any signal on
the deep on a Depot assay for those
samples is false signal and whereas the
vitro SAS a I would say is an example if
you had 10 mixed per deciliter for vitro
than you might have an average of 0.1
for D bill in surveys that I've looked
at and for other methods at the same
concentration then you have anywhere
from point 3 to point 7 makes per
deciliter is the average forgiving
method so you're talking about a
significant amount of false cross
reactivity that limits the clinical
utility of a conjugated bilirubin
measurement and obviously the last the
last thing is since you're running a BBC
slide you're getting a conjugated
bilirubin measurement on every neonate
which is great because you've got a
method this relative this extremely
specific actually so if you get a
significant elevation of conjugated
bilirubin and neonates and you know that
you have to look at that patient clothes
reviews as the sample has been degraded
by light or else they have elevated
conjugated bilirubin to a level that you
really
assess whether or not they have an
infection or pedo biliary issues and
with that I would like to say thank you
to everyone who attended this talk and I
will field any questions that have come
up during the talk thank you very much
okay I'm looking through some of some of
the questions that have come online I
see online that the features micro
slides are used in conjunction with the
analyzing systems but I wonder if in any
handheld analyzing tools for in office
or at home use is of interest or in
development at ortho clinical
Diagnostics it's definitely something
that that has been discussed that that's
about where I was I would leave it on
the one place where I can say that these
slides are being used commonly is in the
veteran veterinary offices there's a
third party that actually has developed
has developed analyzers that run the
feature of slides and they use them in
vet offices for for measurements animals
and and there are published reference
ranges for vitro slides for a variety of
different animal species ok so that
answers that question
okay comment about sample size for a
neonate and point-of-care testing for
totally conjugated bilirubin beatrice
BBC slide a say this the BBC slide
utilizes i don't know the exact buy but
it's around ten microliters and if you
use that if you use the right types of
containers then really that the the
biggest volume requirement is dead
volume that you need to have within the
well in order to draw a sample now so
you're probably talking about needing on
the order of a belief depending on the
instrument probably a minimum of 50
microliters in a tube in order to
measure it if you're running a panel of
assays you know that benefit is kind of
carried across all those assays because
i book none of the features micro slide
assays use more than I believe sixteen
microliters and most of them are on the
order of ten or twelve microliters or
less so you know you require a very
small sample for running even panels of
assays and and you know obviously the
BBC side is only one slide so there's
not two assays to be run so that's one
of the reasons why I think the BBC [ __ ]
I mean the beet roast analyzers are very
popular in the pediatric setting it's a
combination of having differentiated
bilirubin assay and having a platform
that's really designed to handle small
sample volumes thanks for the question
thanks for both the questions alright
and let's see that looks like it in
terms of questions and there's a couple
of comments here that say thank you very
much for for the comments on the
presentation itself and I see a comment
there about making the presentation
available with an email address and I
will definitely take care of that and as
I mentioned there will be a chat it will
be starting in just just a few minutes
as soon as I can log off and log back
onto that and again I'll say thank you
very much to everybody who has attended
and have a great rest of the meeting
you
you